10 月 6 號
OpenAI 一口氣公開了一大批 AI 做出來的數學新結果
兩天後
一位費爾茲獎得主在線上講座說
他寫進論文
演講跟經費申請的研究題目
全部被解掉了，一題不剩
你們可以想像
這段時間，這場演講我差不多每 3 天就得改一次
尤其是昨天
講話的人叫 Hugo Duminil-Copin
2022 年的費爾茲獎得主
在法國高等科學研究所跟日內瓦大學當教授
他研究的是滲流，一塊滿是小孔的石頭
孔多到某個程度，水會突然從滲不過去
變成整塊流得通
這場是法國數學學會 10 月 8 號開的線上講座
他講第一場
可是對職業數學家來說
真正的轉變，至少對我來說
我發現這一天會比預期早很多的那一刻
是在 4 月
一方面，Lean 證明開始系統化、自動化
那真的很驚人
另一方面…我老是搞混
忘了是 5.5 還是 5.6
總之，新的 ChatGPT 出來了
講一件跟我們的研究、跟我的研究直接有關的事
我有個同事，好玩而已
那是他這輩子第一次用 LLM
他丟進去的，就是他手上在做的題目
那道題我自己大概 10 年前也做過
我有一篇登在 Duke 的論文，70 頁
證出了維度大於 4 的情況
這位同事前一年
證出了同一個猜想維度大於 2 的情況
他就想說好玩，丟進 ChatGPT
問它「你做得出來嗎？」問的是真正的那個猜想
那是 Benjamini 跟 Schramm 提出來的猜想
要證的是所有大於 1 的維度
而且維度可以是碎形那種
結果 ChatGPT 給了他一頁的證明
漂亮得不得了
而且你沒辦法說
它只是去哪篇我們沒看過的論文，把對的論證找出來
你想想這個年輕人有多震驚
他埋頭做了好幾年的題目，一秒就被解掉了
重點不在證明簡不簡單
那個證明很漂亮，而且很短
我們當時就想：「好吧，很明顯，結束了
剩下的只是幾週、幾個月的事」
後來的發展證明我們沒說錯
5 月那道有名的 Erdos 題目
我們又看到同一種事
AI 在這上面已經強得很明顯
可是那種本事，該怎麼說
跟我們職業數學家的本事對不太上
也就是說，這兩次都很典型
都看得到一種所謂「長距離的類比」
有一條連結，大家一直沒看到
可是這條連結一旦被找出來
證明本身其實沒有那麼複雜
所以靠的比較是百科全書式的知識
還有把很遠的東西類比起來的能力
他這一行有一道猜想
寫作 θ(p_c)=0
它問的是，孔剛好多到臨界點的那一刻
水到底流不流得過去
三維空間的版本
幾十年來沒有人證得出來
我自己在這件事上，也有一段小經歷
9 月初，應該說 8 月底到 9 月初
大概是這樣，我們聽到一些傳言
就只是傳言
說這一行最大的猜想，至少是最有名的那一道
叫做 θ(p_c) = 0
已經被 Anthropic 解掉了
我們只有傳言，其實什麼都不知道
沒有第一手的消息
被聯絡過的人，如果真的有人被聯絡過
也沒有把消息傳出來
所以我們完全被蒙在鼓裡
然後 9 月 2 日，我們發現了一份 Lean 證明
沒有任何說明
像我這種跟電腦處不太來的人
老實說，我覺得自己一下子老了一倍
連自己在看什麼都看不懂
結果得靠一位同事，用 AI 本身
把這份 Lean 證明
轉成一篇完全讀不懂的論文
我很佩服我們幾位年輕同事
他們硬是把這篇可怕的東西讀完
現在正在重寫
像今天早上，Arthur 就寫出一篇
比較短，也比較好懂
可是背後得花真功夫，才弄得懂它
對我們來說，這次跟之前那些結果不一樣
這是我們這一行真正最大的難題
是我們的燈塔之一
一路引著大家做研究的東西
就這樣被解掉了
就在 6 天後…當然，這個消息
我們決定不對外講
我們不太想讓它上新聞
可是 6 天後，Navier-Stokes 被證出來了
那一段大家都經歷過了
應該說，被宣布證出來了
結果所有媒體一窩蜂撲上去
因為以前我們就是這樣找媒體的
你看，千禧年難題，你看，費爾茲獎，這一類的
所以這次，套句話說，OpenAI 中了頭獎
每家媒體都拿它上頭條
可是我得說，傷害早在那之前就造成了
對數學界的衝擊
可惜事情變得…我真的跟「10 月」處不來，抱歉
可是事情變得更糟，因為兩天前，你們都知道
有 350 道題目被證出來了
都是重要的題目，每一題都是
至少我想，我們很多人
光是證出其中一題，就會高興得不得了
簡單說，這幾個月的我大概是這樣
有點慌…其實是嚇到僵住
這是週二半夜的我
我放了好幾台卡車
因為我要讓你們看看，我這邊災情有多慘
這上面每一題
我都在演講裡講過
寫進論文
寫進經費申請，過去的跟未來的
說真的
結果全部被解掉了
沒有一題沒被解掉
所以我現在的處境，可以說前所未有
就是我所有的研究方向…至少對我來說是前所未有
我所有的研究方向，都被解掉了
有好幾個方向
一出來就是 6 篇論文，加起來超過 600 頁
講滲流的共形不變性
那是我們的大計畫之一，而且進展得很順
可是看起來，我們離終點比想像的還遠
至少，希望我們找得到短一點的證明
總之，600 頁
還有那個有名的自迴避隨機漫步
我想很多人都聽過
聽過我演講的人，大概都聽我講過這題
週二晚上，我打開一篇論文
心想，這篇我完全看不懂
我花了一整天才搞懂，那其實是第 13 篇
前面還有 12 篇
加起來超過 1000 頁
9 月 11 號
25 位費爾茲獎得主發了一封聯名信
說 AI 公司搶著拿數學難題當跑分
正在傷害數學
這場講座的標題，就是那封信的標題
後面再補上「28 天後」
先講房間裡那頭大象
我知道大家現在很難
不在這件事上選邊站
我不認為自己是反 AI 的人
我只是自己不用它
有些情況用它完全合適，這我一點意見都沒有
可是現在 AI 被拿來用的方式
大公司的用法，還有我們一部分同行的用法，不是全部
在我看來完全不對
這就是我們一開始幾個人私下討論的事
後來我們邀請所有願意的費爾茲獎得主一起加入
就是寫一份聲明，講清楚這個問題
就是 AI 的用法，特別是「挖礦」
玩電玩的人會說「刷」
一題一題，有系統地把題目打掉
就拿 θ(p_c) 來說
我後來才發現，有個人試過要聯絡我
這個人跟我講得非常清楚
其實是電腦自己在挑，應該說是程式
自己決定要解哪些題目
當然，是根據我們累積下來的知識
可是這已經是數學發現的全自動化了
不得不說，這封聲明的影響很有限
我想它也許讓數學界
一起…應該說，讓大家敢講話了
對 AI 公司的影響
看週二那次公布就知道
等於零
而且最重要的一點是
「別把引導我們的那些未解猜想全部拆掉」
這一點完全沒有被聽進去
非得證明它能把我們屠殺殆盡
而且是最徹底的那種
這有點奇怪，因為我想我們沒有人懷疑過
經過 Navier-Stokes 那件事
他們有本事做這種事
這件事很急
不是以後再來討論就好
這關係到現在的年輕人
我帶的博士生跟博士後
現在全陷入恐慌，我懂他們
大學部跟碩士班的學生
也在問同一個問題，很簡單
數學還有未來嗎？
我還想講兩點…不，三點
很重要的一點是，我覺得我們整體
在溝通跟資訊上出了問題
這些公司就愛話題
所以做事、對外講話，都把話題衝到最大
這是有後果的
不知道別人怎樣，像我這種倒楣的
週二就差不多知道，幾小時內就要公布了
那真的是地獄
我是說，有個記者先聯絡我
所以我知道它要來了
一開始跟我說是某個時間
結果不是那個時間
改了 3 次
壓力大到難以想像
公布出來了，「我們搞定數學了」，云云
我是說，他們要怎麼做，我們管不著
可是我們自己怎麼做、怎麼講話，我們管得著
老實說，這方面我們也不是沒有問題
今年夏天
他寫了一篇短文談 AI 跟數學
自認寫得很節制
結果收到一堆措辭很兇的信
寄信的還是科學家
我很不幸，在那篇文章裡寫了
我自己在創作的時候不用 AI
我寫的就是這一句
我馬上就被歸類了
而且只要同行開了頭
我跟你們保證，記者跟輿論會放大 1000 倍
把我歸成反 AI 的，就因為我這樣做
我還是要強調
我說的就只有，我自己不用 AI
而且只限我自己創作的時候
既然我學不乖，我就這樣收尾
最後講講我自己打算怎麼做
這樣正好讓覺得我反 AI 的人更有把握
當然，我會試著把這幾百頁的證明讀懂
給你們一個概念
OpenAI 公布的那些論文裡
光是直接引用到我的
就有 3500 頁
而我這輩子總共發表了 3700 頁
所以我得吞下、讀懂的，差不多是我一輩子寫的量
只不過，有引用到我的
不見得是我特別在意的
我真正在意的論文跟題目，這些還不到一半
有很多是我打算以後要做的
或是我正在做的
只是我還沒做出夠有趣、夠重要的東西
所以 OpenAI 那批論文沒引用到
所以要讀懂這一切，得靠大家一起
跟我的同事、我的學生一起
我們的目標，是讓這些結果周圍重新有人在做研究
再來，繼續自己做研究，我自己是不靠 AI
這裡我要強調一點
尤其是對大眾講話的時候，我發現
我真正傳出去的，比較是一種能力
理解難題、面對難題的能力
還有我怎麼處理自己的情緒，諸如此類
我跟你們保證，16 歲的孩子才不在乎
什麼自迴避隨機漫步、什麼滲流
可是研究到底是什麼
解開一道題目，是怎樣一場腦袋裡的冒險
這個他們就聽得很入迷
所以我覺得，我們這群人帶來的
不只是一堆附上證明的定理
甚至是我們讀懂了的證明
好啦，老實說，證明還是得讀懂
可是就算這樣，我覺得還不只如此
從某個角度看，數學也是一門人文科學
也就是一門把人當成研究對象的學問
在這裡，研究的是人怎麼抽象思考
人怎麼面對難題
人怎麼在思考上超越自己
第 3 點，多投入科普
多跟一般大眾、跟中小學生接觸
這一點，我是向每個人伸出手
我覺得數學關在象牙塔裡的時代
很可惜，已經過去了
想對社會有貢獻，就得捲起袖子親自下去做
我不是說每個人都得去找 11 歲的小學生
那不見得是最容易的事
可是科普能做的事多得是
多投入教學
我大概會花比以前更多的時間在教學上
整個研究方向一次被清空之後
Duminil-Copin 打算先把那幾千頁讀懂
然後不靠 AI，繼續自己想
他想傳下去的
是人自己想通一道難題的那段路
原影片 32 分鐘
後面他還講了兩件事
一件是他們團隊猜到 OpenAI 要大公布了
週一晚上趕在最後一刻
先把自己的一篇論文貼上網
另一件是
他覺得以後證明大概不會再從數學家的腦袋裡長出來了
可是一個點子從數學家一路傳到一般人的那條長路
還是得有人顧
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。